we're on problem 167
if 1 plus 1 over x is equal to
2
minus 2 over x then what does x equal
well the first thing i would do is i
just i don't like these x's in the
denominator so let's just multiply both
sides of this equation by x
so i'll get
x
plus x over x just 1
equals
2x minus 2
let's see now i can subtract 1 from both
sides
actually let's add 2 to both sides so
you get x
plus 3 is equal to 2x
let's subtract x from both sides you get
3 is equal to x
and that's choice e
i think i have the hiccups
hope you don't notice or if you do it i
hope it doesn't bother you problem 168.
last year for every 100 million vehicles
that traveled on a certain highway 96
vehicles were involved in accidents so
96
vehicles for every 100
million so 100 times what a million is
ten to the sixth
vehicles
if three billion vehicles traveled on
the highway last year
how many of those vehicles were involved
in accidents so this is the you could
view this as the fraction that will be
involved in accident so we just multiply
that times the total number of vehicles
well that's
times
three times
a billion and they even write out a
billion is one with nine zeros so it's
three times ten to the ninth
right so if we simplify this a little
bit let's see what we can do so 100
times 10 to the sixth this is the same
thing as
1 times 10 to the 8th
right you could view this as 10 to the
second
times 10 to the sixth is 10 to the
eighth and let's see if you have a 10 to
the ninth in the denominator divided by
10 to the eighth
this cancels out and you're just left
with a 10.
so the numerator just becomes well the
denominator becomes 1 and the numerator
becomes 96 times 30
and 96
times 30 is
see let's put a
0 here and then 3 times 6 is 18
three times nine is twenty seven plus
one is twenty eight
so two thousand
eight hundred
and eighty
accidents or how many vehicles are
involved in accidents
two thousand eight eighty
c
i think this number is low compared to
the reality i think actually it's closer
in the in the 40 000 range anyway next
question all right that's what they want
how many of those vehicles are involved
in accidents yeah we multiply the
fraction that have an accident times the
total number of vehicles and then you
get
you get your answer two thousand eight
hundred and eighty next question
one hundred sixty nine
thirty percent of the members of a swim
team have passed
the life-saving test so 30 percent
passed
among the members who have not passed
the test 12 have taken the preparatory
course so this is a 70 percent
not passed and they say that 12 have
taken course so 12 course
and 30 have not taken the course
30
not taken the course how many members
are in the swim club so how many people
have not passed the test
well they said that 12 have taken a
course 30 haven't so i'm assuming that's
all of them so the 70 that have not
passed
that is 12 plus 30 is equal to 42
and this is 70 of the total people in
the swim club so 70 percent of the total
is equal to 42
so the total
is equal to 42 divided by 0.7
and so let's see 42 divided by 7 would
be 6 but since we're dividing it by 1 10
of that it's going to be equal to 60 and
that makes sense 70 of 60 is 42. so
there are 60 people in the swim club and
that's a
problem 170
in a certain company the ratio of the
number of managers to the number of
production line workers is 5 to 72 so
managers to workers is equal to 5
to 72.
if eight additional production line
workers were to be hired
the ratio of the number of managers to
the number of production line workers
would be five to seventy four
so if we hire eight more workers right
this is eight more workers
then the ratio is equal to 5
5
to
74
5 to 74. how many managers
how many managers does the company have
so this is interesting when i well let's
think of it this way there's a quick way
to think about it and then there's a
algebraic way and we'll do both of them
but when
when we add eight to the bottom of this
when we add eight to the number of
workers the ratio
the ratio actually only increased by two
right the ratio only increased by two so
what's happening is we probably have
four times as many workers as this ratio
predicts so the ratio is probably
it's probably twenty two and what's four
times is 288
right
and let's think about that logic because
20 over 288 this is 5 over 72 if you
were divide the top and the bottom by 4.
and if you were to add 8 to the bottom
if you were to add 8 to the bottom you'd
get 20 over 296 and then if you divide
this by 4 if you just take this the
lowest form reduced form you get 5
divide that by 4.
this divided by 4 is what it's 74.
so if you see what i that intuition that
that i'm talking about that when you add
eight workers it only increased this
reduced form by two that means that this
reduced form is probably one-fourth of
the real numbers right because uh
because two is one-fourth of eight if
that doesn't make sense to you don't
worry about it but if you did it this
way you could say oh there must be 20
managers and that'd be a very fast way
of of solving this problem but we could
also do it algebraically so you could
say
you could use this information to say
five times the workers
is equal to
72 times
the managers
and then you could use this information
to say
say 5 times the workers
plus
40 i'm just cross multiplying so 5 times
w 8 is equal to
74 times the managers
and now we can we can do some
algebra let's let's subtract this from
this so let me say minus 5w
is equal to minus 72
times the managers subtract this from
this these cancel out you get 40
is equal to
74 minus 72 is 2 times the managers so
then you get the managers are equal to
20 which is what we figure out the first
time maybe this is simpler for you and
and i would probably do that on the exam
just to make sure i didn't make a
careless mistake
next question
what am i on okay that was question 170
so we're on 171.
if
x minus 1 squared is equal to 400 which
of the following could be the value of x
minus 1. x minus 1 squared is equal to
400 so that means that x
minus 1 is equal to positive 20 the
positive square root of 400 or and don't
forget this this also means that x minus
1 could equal minus 20 right because -20
squared is also 400 the negative square
root
in this case if you add 1 to both sides
you get x is equal to 21
in this case if you add 1 to both sides
you get x is equal to minus 19.
and they have
they have oh so that's that's what the
values of x are so what could be a value
of x minus 5
so x minus 5 that's what they ask for
they're not asking for a value of x x
minus 5 in this case would be what's 21
minus 5 that's 16 x minus 5 in this case
minus 19 minus 5
minus 19 minus 5 that's minus 24. so x
minus 5 could be 16 or it could be -24
and they only have this one there so
it's choice c
so they were just testing to see if you
remember that
x minus 1 could be the minus square root
of 400 the negative square root
problem 172
which of the following describes all
values of x for which
one minus x squared
is greater than or equal to
zero
so let's i don't know let's add x
squared to both sides of this equation
right so then you get
1 x squared plus minus x or that's zero
is greater than
or equal to x squared i'm just going to
switch it because that's just how i
think x squared is less than or equal to
1.
so if i'm going to square a number we
know that x squared we're dealing with
real numbers so x squared is going to be
a positive number so the only way that i
can square a positive number
and having it and have it be less than
or equal to 1 is if x itself is less
than or equal to 1 or it could be the
less or could be greater than or equal
to negative 1 right because those
numbers will square
to being positive so x
would be
less than or equal to 1 but it can also
be greater than or equal to negative 1.
and you could try it try negative
one-half negative one-half squared is
positive one-fourth right no matter what
whether it's positive or negative this
is going to be a positive number and the
magnitude can be at least at most one so
that goes takes us from -1 to 1 and even
0 works so let's see if that's one of
the choices yep that's choice e
and i'll see you in the next video